right yeah so ipagamine hypergamy is
that women want to date are constantly
trying to date up no no no no wait wait
wait wait wait wait wait wait women are
constantly trying to date up they're
trying to get trying to get the best
deal that they can get men men will get
a deal and be like you know what I'm
actually quite happy with this and hang
on let me finish men will get a deal
they will get a woman who's a six out of
ten
she takes all the boxes and they will
Coast for the rest of their life wait
wait wait
so women are always looking for that
level up right which is why which is why
if I was to ask all of you women here
right now the types of men that you want
you would probably list a man in the top
20 of men right but if you're listening
to Madison the top 20 of men what's
gonna happen is what if a man comes up
he's in the top 15 wait a man that comes
to the top ten percent
no no no but listen
you just show me you just showed me his
picture you just saw him though
yeah we don't have the same thing but
but does it not go down to like back for
example there's a traditional way of a
man needing to provide for a woman and
you know I'm saying are positions in
life even through traditional culture
does that not work fools to you when you
exactly no I mean because when he's
talking about women trying to get the
highest highest number
I'm trying to go like from hair to hair
career-wise money why as home family for
example so exactly that's what you boys
I'll tell you why you take Kim
Kardashian for for an example right Kim
Kardashian started out with Ray J right
yeah then she went to Reggie Miller he
was an NFL football player right and
then there was an I think there was
another NFL football player right and
then she found Kanye but she went down
but Kanye was the Pinnacle of Kim
Kardashian's
um the man that she could find right so
what's she done so no what's she done I
don't know hang on but what's she done
she started to breed with because in her
in her heart and her mind she was like
this is Top This is top level so she's
she's now got four children for Kanye
right then wait wait wait wait wait wait
wait wait let's wait wait yeah she's got
four children for Kanye right she felt
like she found the Pinnacle he's a
billionaire she's a multi-millionaire
yeah she felt like that was her level
after that she divorced Connie where's
she gone to
do you know what that's true Pete
Davidson right and you know why because
after having four children
so after so after Kanye West from here
on out it's it's downhill for Kim
Kardashian because she's got four
children
let's not capped though as girls like
how of course you want a person of
course wait of course you want to
reproduce with the best guy you can no
yeah
the way I see it is that as girls we
always look for the best because
we want them like we don't I don't know
I'm speaking from personal experience
anyways and
if I meet a guy that's got everything I
want I'm not cheating on him I'm not
looking at other guys I'm not worried
you know what I mean but if you see if
you're dating someone and you see like
things that are missing in that person
automatically your eyes gonna Wonder
guys they can have a 1010 goal
everything lay down for them whatever
and they'll still cheat
I have a question for you would you
rather have a guy that had everything
you wanted but he cheated from time to
time but you were the main chick or a
guy let's say let's say you're five deal
breakers he has three three of the five
let's tell you five things you want to
use three
I'm not gonna lie but he doesn't cheat
I'm taking the cheetah because let me
tell you one thing yeah that's very in
that that's okay
most girls would most girls would yeah
only because I can't give that guy that
has those what like what I would give to
someone who has everything I need would
you kind of look the other way I'd be
like I didn't see it
was that easy
in my head I like to say out loud I
would take the free but if he cheated
subtly and didn't embarrass me yeah
if there were no public embarrassment
and he cheated very subtly yeah
you already be inside [ __ ] like of
course
do you know what it is it's not a public
team
as a woman we already go through
menstrual cycle going to work having to
look good and it's not even just looking
good for men some people do that
personally I don't I love fashion I just
love to feel good Within Myself in it
that being a woman is a lot yeah I have
to say life is crazy life is easy life
is no life is easy when we're skinny
people looking pretty that's what I
would say woman as a Young Man life is
harder
it's always right 100 100 that's a goal
as long as you're pretty
that's all you need to do thank you
yes we could hear each other we're
speaking over each other let's not let's
not do that as a man if you're not
successful top tier you need to be
multiple things multiple as a woman if
you're just pretty that can just run
that can run you don't need this you
don't need to be a woman
obviously don't get me wrong
the reason why you're actually correct
is because a man that's got a man who is
successful right a man who is a
multi-millionaire had to go through
Blood Sweat and Tears and hard work
consistently to become a millionaire you
can be 22 and pretty and and a Instagram
model and that man can go into your DMs
and say look and I'm in Dubai and I've
got a yacht right I'll fly you over and
that he can have 12 women on his yacht
yeah right who are dancing and having a
great time and those women are literally
actually on on benefits in the UK right
but that man has had to toil and work
and Blood Sweat and Tears and women
they're trying to say women you you
don't understand you live life on Easy
Street you know you don't understand you
live like men if you find a successful
man trust me that man has had to go
through the hell to become successful
you could you can actually be next to a
successful man and not have done much
my point is
as a man as you or me
that
that part of your time it's not going to
be forever exactly we settle my fair
enough we settled can I add something
and then uh like from my own experience
I came to this country when I was
younger right from where from Senegal
okay uh I did I've did a lot of stuff
right I've I've did crazy stuff but when
it was time for me to get married I went
back home with Senegal I went back to
Senegal yeah I found the right woman for
me because I knew what I saw from what I
saw in this country there's no chance
for the women in this country for the
women in this country there was no you
wouldn't marry a woman no country no oh
there's there's one percent chance right
okay because I'm not saying every woman
that I meet in the city on Friday night
or Saturday night all the same yeah
no no no you know what it is
we man we we look forward to that
settlement
okay and for us a settlement is getting
married finding the right woman and
having children and having children and
settle yes right yeah for for women
their beauty
the older you get it it goes down it
goes down yeah yeah and as it goes down
it's harder for you to settle yes yeah
yeah it's harder for you to settle it's
time
of big time now the other thing is but
the thing is at the peak time is when
you should be trying to settle exactly
and that's the thing about a lot of
women of this they don't realize they
don't realize
they want to do City Girl stuff and then
when they get to 30. oh my God like what
the hell am I doing women
um did you feel like you were simping
for girls in London which is why you had
to go to Senegal no no no the reason the
reason the reason why I went back is
because it's because one it's because
one I didn't I I I don't trust the girls
I see here raising my kids
because I have seen women
I don't think you can't find a wife in
this country but it's about the odds
it's about the names see if you're in
this country it'll be odds you might
have to go through 50 girls to find one
that you could potentially marry I feel
like in your country because the culture
is different you probably have to only
go through five girls to find out yeah
but I think we're talking about SIM PIN
right yeah the thing is with women in
the Western Market and women in the
Western World they seem like they want
guys to Simply do you know wait wait
they want guys to simp for them okay so
what happens is when a man simps for a
woman right it puts him in the feminine
and it puts a woman in her masculine
yeah and so what what happens is is that
the man starts to be a woman and a woman
starts to be a man and so what happened
and and so I'm just saying and so what
happens is is that the Dynamics of the
relationship get skewed and so women
while they may like because women
generally lack attention you're women
you lack attention right however too
much attention from a simp you ain't
gonna respect him as many of you know I
was just banned on Tick Tock and we are
demonetized on a daily basis on this
platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible